hey what's up guys it's Rob and welcome
to my tutorial for the movements ristar
boomerang on my last thing to start
boomerang video I got some requests to
try to do a three-pointed boomerang and
after some trials and fails I finally
came up with this one that flies like
this I also called and challenge Jeremy
Shafer who's trying to make his own
boomerang and he made one that flies
just like this you can check out his
video by clicking the card above or the
link in the description after you learn
how to make it and also throw it like I
show at the end of the video people are
really gonna want one so if you do enjoy
it be sure to give it a big thumbs up
down below and share it that way they
can have their own and they don't have
to try to take yours I'm using an
eight-and-a-half by eleven letter slice
printer paper like this which will then
turn into a triangle with three equal
sides this is also known as an
equilateral triangle and each side is
nine point seven five or nine and
three-quarter inches long that makes the
height basically the width of the paper
which is eight and a half inches knowing
all this here's the bonus comment now
you don't need to measure it but you do
need to be as neat as possible so if you
have a ruler I'd recommend using it the
first time you try to make sure that
your dimensions of the triangle are
correct to make an equilateral triangle
we can use any size rectangle like I
said I'm using eight and a half by
eleven and I'm going to hold it with the
longer edges vertical like this and fold
the left side in half to the right side
lengthwise by lining the two edges up as
neatly as possible hold it there and
make a crease on the left side then you
can open it back up and this next fold
is the most important we're going to
take the upper right corner and slide it
along this new middle fold until this
top edge here is from the middle all the
way to the upper left so just slide the
corner along the middle there until that
top edge lines up with the upper-left
corner just like that so once you have
it positioned there then you can make a
crease all throughout the right side
like that here you can see the upper
right corner was folded down to the
center crease so the top edge aligns
with the middle and upper left if you
are better with measurements and you're
using letter size paper like me then you
can make a mark on the middle here
that's nine centimeters from the bottom
and draw a line from the middle point
here all the way to the upper left and
that should measure eight and a half
then you could just take the right
corner here fold it directly on to that
line and go from there
once you have that fold we're going to
turn the paper counterclockwise like
this and take the upper right corner and
fold it directly along this edge so that
the top lines up with the left side just
like this once you have it lined up like
that then you can make another crease on
the right side I like to tear it but if
you do want to cut it that's fine I'm
going to crease it really sharp on the
right and really sharp here with my
fingernail on the left then I'm going to
open both of the edges up and flip it
over I'm going to start the tear here on
top and just pull the two edges apart do
the same on the other side and there you
go
you have an equilateral triangle if you
made the equilateral triangle properly
you'll notice that all sides are the
same and it looks the same no matter
which way you hold it if you take the
top corner of the triangle and fold it
down on this crease we already have here
it should wind up directly in the middle
of the bottom side now we're going to
split the triangle in half along its
three corners or vertices in these
directions we can take the bottom left
corner here and fold it to the right
bottom corner by taking the corners
meeting them up like this and also
meaning up the two edges here once you
line it up like this you could hold it
and make a crease on the left side then
you could open it up again now we could
do the same with the other corners take
the bottom left and join it to the top
and crease it along the bottom and then
take the bottom right meet it to the top
as well and do the same thing so now you
should have something like this and I'm
just going to draw on the new creases
that we just made so you could see them
easier
at the middle of the triangle there's an
intersection point and from that
intersection point three go to the
corner and three go to the sides or the
side lines I've drawn those in red the
next fold are important and will
determine the width of the airfoil flap
on the front and because we want all
three equal I recommend you use a ruler
on the red side lines I'm going to make
three marks a quarter inch from the
center so here's one there's two and
there's three and don't forget that the
quarter inch is this one right here
we're now going to take all three sides
and fold them directly on to the points
that we made on the side lines here I'm
just going to rotate it like this so
it's a little easier for me and I'm
gonna take the top here and meet this
point here directly on to that top point
that I have then I'm going to make a
crease along the top and I'm just gonna
make it nice and sharp by running my
fingernail against it then we could open
it up and I was going to rotate it now
do the same with this one so just fold
the second one down to the point and
give it a sharp crease on top and then
you could open it rotate it and fold the
last one down and give it a sharp crease
now you can unfold it and you should
have something that looks like this
we're now going to take this bottom
right corner and we're just going to
pinch it together like this so just take
the two edges and pinch them together
and then just run your fingernail
against it like this and then we're
going to set it down and we're going to
take the bottom edge and the right edge
and press them in like this so that
they're completely flat and that the
corner is kind of just like a little tag
sticking up once these two edges are
both flattened down we're going to take
this corner here that we've been holding
on to and then just pull the corner down
like this and then make a crease right
around here
then we can just open it up and we're
just going to rotate it so that this
edge is now on the bottom then we could
do the same thing pinch the bottom right
corner make sure it's aligned on both
sides and then flatten the bottom and
the right edges all the way down like
that and pull the corner down and
flatten it out then we could work on the
last one so just rotate it pinch the
corner flatten the edges and pull the
corner down and flatten it so
everything's going to be put in a
clockwise direction like this so just
put all the corners and the edges like
that as you'll see they're kind of going
in this direction and flatten it out so
you should have something that looks
just like this somes gonna flip it over
like this and you'll see here we have
those three marks on the back that's not
what we're going to be paying attention
to for this next step we're actually
going to be making a mark in the center
of the paper right here and we're going
to hold the triangle so that the point
is facing down like this and we're going
to be taking this edge here and folding
it all the way down to this line along
this fold that we already have in the
paper so just set it down on the table
and I'm just going to take this whole
edge and bring it down like this
straight down to the middle and make
sure that this fol stays on top of
itself now when you do that just hold it
right here where the crease is and walk
your finger to the left and this might
try to lift up what you can do is just
go like this and flatten it out first
and then really flatten it on top like
that and we're just going to walk our
finger up to this point right here you
don't want to fold this down so we're
just gonna walk our finger in like this
and press right there like that and then
give it a good crease from here all the
way to the end then you can open it up
and we're just gonna rotate it and do
the same exact thing take the next edge
and fold it all the way down to the
center point and walk your finger to the
left flatten the edge out and then press
down in that little pocket behind the
right point that's sticking up same
thing with the last one we're just gonna
fold the edge all the way down to the
middle and walk our fingers to the left
as you'll see there's a little overhang
on the left side and then you could just
press in the pocket to the right and you
should have something that looks like
this now now we're gonna do the same
thing that we did on the other side when
we closed it down in a clockwise
direction except this time what's going
to be in a counterclockwise direction as
you'll see here I tore it a little bit
but it shouldn't be a problem that was
just
use the pen we're just gonna press down
like this so that this edge is
completely flat and also press the left
side down now at the same time until you
see these two edges meet in the middle
and then just flatten it out like that
then you can open these two and do the
same thing twist it clockwise fold down
on this bottom edge and also on the top
edge so push right here and then push
right here and press down in the middle
all the way down like that
open it twist it clockwise push down on
the bottom edge and make sure that these
two edges stay together press down until
it goes all the way to the middle all
you need to do basically just tuck
everything into the middle like that and
it should be in a counterclockwise
direction flatten it out now we could
flip it over like this and I'm going to
fold this over hang down all the way
down to here so I'll zoom in so you can
see it I'm gonna take this fold it all
the way down even in the corner where it
doesn't want to go just kind of press it
down like that and fold it all the way
down on the arm and give it a really
good crease and rotate it do the same
exact thing fold it all the way down
especially in the corner you can kind of
just give it a little tug and fold it
down just like that so it will be a
little bit angled that's okay just try
to press it down as far down as you can
but don't pull too hard do the last one
and you're all done and I'll show you
how to make the boomerang fly really
well and how to throw it so I'm going to
show you why we need to make sure that
it's really neat and we have to adjust
it so I'm gonna I just finish this one
I'm going to hold it with the flaps on
the left and give it a shot okay so kind
of fell the ground didn't come back
looking at the boomerang I can kind of
see that these are sticking up so what
I'm going to do is first hold it with
the flaps facing away from me like this
on the table and I'm gonna press down
making sure it's nice and flat
increasing both edges of the arms with
my fingernails then I'm just gonna lift
it up and as you can see here I'm just
gonna crease every single airfoil or
flap with my fingernail very sharply and
now what I'm going to do is holding the
flaps facing downwards like this on the
table I'm gonna take my finger and my
pointer and thumb and I'm gonna round
off the tip like this and the arm so the
tip curves up just a little bit not too
much just like that and do that with all
three of them
so curl the wings and the tips a little
bit away from the flaps I'd like that
alright so let's see how it flies now
and now I'm going to hold it between my
pointer and middle finger like this
right behind the tip of the boomerang
not on the tip I'm going to hold it
right at the edge or the end of the
airfoil right about there
and I'm gonna hold it between my pointer
and middle finger like this making sure
that the flaps are facing to the left
and I'm going to curl my wrist like this
and I'm going to basically flick it out
like that and let it roll out of my hand
so I'm going to throw it kind of
vertically tilt it a little bit to the
left let's give it a shot
there you go that's much better the one
that I made with eleven by seventeen
inch paper it slides a little bit better
actually
[Music]
thanks for watching my video for the new
ninja Tristar boomerang I hope you
enjoyed it if you did give it a thumbs
up down below and if you're not already
subscribed click to subscribe and the
notification bell so you stay notified
paper boomerang can be really sensitive
to bends and stuff like that in the
paper so if you find it flying funky
after a few throws you'll have to
reflash it sharpen the creases again and
also fix the tips to make it fly well
again let me know what you thought of
the video in the comments below and also
what you'd like to see next and I might
try to make it thanks and I'll see you
next time